dieser ausbruch ist ein albtraum für
alle nachtschwärmer mehrere mitarbeiter
und besucher der szenebar katze in der
hamburger stern schatz sind positiv auf
das kona virus getestet worden
man befürchtet jetzt dass ich natürlich
auch noch weitere menschen angesteckt
haben könnten
rund 500 leute wurden schon von den
ämtern kontaktiert aber von vielen
fehlen die echten kontaktdaten da sie
falsche namen oder nummern angegeben
haben da geht es um rund 100 leute jetzt
und genauere details kennt meine
kollegin nadja aswad mir nun
zugeschaltet naja wie genau sucht man
jetzt also nach den rund 100 leuten die
man nicht erreicht hat hallo
die gesundheitsbehörde aus hamburg hat
gestern abend die sie vorfall öffentlich
gemacht und hat tatsächlich so eine art
öffentlichkeit verhandlungen gestartet
also man hat eine mitteilung
herausgegeben und fordert alle leute auf
die sich am 5
am 8 9 oder am 9.9 abends oder nachts in
der katze aufgehalten haben sich beim
gesundheitsamt zu melden da gibt es eine
telefonnummer
und da sollen die leute anrufen die
bislang noch nicht vom gesundheitsamt
kontaktiert worden sind weil 500 hat man
schon erreichen
wenn dies jetzt auch direkt vor der
katze wir sehen gerade ist es dort jetzt
natürlich zu 100 leute das ist natürlich
für sie selber wichtig dass sie wissen
dass ihm jemand kontakt gekommen sind
aber auch eine gefahr falls sich
angesteckt haben
wie muss man sich das ganze vorstellen
haben sich gar nicht in listen
eingetragen haben sie sich als donald
duck eingetragen wie konnte das
überhaupt passieren
bislang wissen wir das ist auch wahr
sehr sehr viele menschen gibt die mit
fantasienamen eingetragen haben den
blocksberg werden armin wenig denn auch
falsche nummern wurden eingetragen und
dann ist es natürlich nicht möglich für
die ämter jemand nicht erreichen
insofern hoffen die ämter das jetzt ganz
viele menschen diesem aufruf folgen und
sich entsprechend helden
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren